[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
foreign
Borneo I'm a sailor I spent a half time
of my life on the on the sea
we have a factory who can convert this
plastic to energy
and so after at the end we can minimize
the footprint carbon of the board
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
it's seven o'clock and this is the Sky
News tonight question and answer program
on the war in Ukraine featuring once
again Professor Michael Clark also had a
special report from besiege severo
Donetsk in the donbassy
[Music]
sorry yeah
Sky news reports from a city on the
front line where thousands of civilians
are still trapped with no real way out
well this is going on all the time
constant barrage it's unbelievable that
there are so many people who are still
living and having to put up with this
Ukraine's Klitschko brothers arrive in
Davos bearing a warning and calling for
the assembled world leaders to help
protect Ukraine
and Russia is accused of weaponizing
Ukraine's Food Supplies with global
consequences as its blockade of Odessa
continues
[Music]
a very good evening well it's been three
months since Russia marched troops
across the border into Ukraine and
millions of people have since been
displaced tens of thousands of troops
and civilians have been killed and still
the conflict continues well coming up in
just a few minutes Professor Michael
Clark will be here answering the
questions that you've been sending to us
throughout the day and just before that
we'll have a special report from Alex
Crawford from the front line in Savannah
Donetsk but first let's bring you
today's other main stories and the UK's
energy price cap is expected to rise in
October to around 2 800 pounds the head
of the energy regulator made the
announcement attributing the need for a
rise to the global gas market and
Russia's invasion of Ukraine the current
price cap of 1971 pounds a year applies
until the 31st of September and that's
already 693 pounds higher than the
previous cap set six months earlier
Downing streets has denied reports that
the Prime Minister urged the civil
servant Sue gray to drop her plans to
publish her report into social events in
number 10 during lockdowns the report is
expected to be released this week and
Boris Johnson has come under renewed
pressure after images emerged of him
raising a glass in Downing Street at a
gathering in November 2020 Sky News
understands at least one person was
fined over that event but not the prime
minister
there are now 71 confirmed cases of
monkey pox in the UK after another 14
were recorded in England there's only
one known infection in Scotland at the
moment and there haven't been any
reported for Wales or Northern Ireland
Health officials say they're keeping an
eye on the situation with extensive
surveillance
well to Ukraine then and despite Fierce
resistance Russia is slowly making some
progress in its campaign in the East and
appears to be on the brink of
surrounding a city that it's feared
could become the next Maria Paul one of
the last big cities under Ukrainian
control in New Hampshire denetsk but
Russian forces are encircling it from
the North and the South the main road
into severo Donetsk is under heavy
bombardment and is now considered to be
too unsafe well our special
correspondent Alex Crawford cameraman
Jake Britton and producer Chris
Cunningham spent 24 hours on the ground
in severe dunetsk and sent this report
on a city and its people living in the
face of the Russian advance
[Music]
the sound of sever Donetsk being pounded
and broken by bombs never stops
[Music]
Ukrainian troops are vastly outnumbered
here can see the Russians blasting their
way in
and underneath all these explosions
there are civilians still trying to
survive
one of the main Bridges linking the city
to the rest of the dombas has been
bombed it's now impossible
so the only way people can now leave an
aid can get in is on this last usable
Bridge which has been hit several times
already
[Music]
this is the city's remaining lifeline
and the ukrainians are only just holding
on to it
if there is a humanitarian disaster
rapidly unfolding with thousands of
people still here
this is a city which Russia would have
banked on being pro-kremlin with strong
links and often with relatives living
there they are very reluctant evacuees
but they are fleeing in the face of this
terrible onslaught
hell you know it's hell uh first uh
everyday
second a lot of them third humanitarian
problems
the sole working hospital is now
surrounded by Russian troops so the only
chance for the injured is to be
evacuated and this is one of the very
few evacuation trips
now it seems like the front is all
around
we can see uh trucks from the Army being
deployed around the city so it seems
very clear that to me it's about to fall
are you glad to be going yeah
yes and no
um I don't know feeling sad about
leaving as well
but time is running out of there to
leave
and these volunteers hope to be back
later to help more flee
a handful are delivering water strapping
bottles on the back of their bikes to
take to those trapped in their homes
joke
he was a musician once
now his world is filled with the sounds
of War
a small moment to collect himself
but we will win he tells us
everything will be okay
thank you he says and kisses my hand
there's work to do
Valerie is another it's far away he
reassures us about the bombing the
strength of these people continues to
astonish
ing it doesn't even Flinch so yeah
we're used to it he says it's been three
months
Valerian his wife Nila won't leave
they've notched up 135 years between
them and they're now enduring bombs
which are landing every few minutes
foreign
it is unrelenting and goes on and on as
he weaves his way back through his
community and takes us to his home where
he and his neighbors have been
Sheltering and where he's been ferrying
food and water to where there seems to
be still a fair amount of people living
his neighbors tell us how hard it is to
get even water
Elena's saying she has to carry two or
three bottles by hand
everyone begins to
end up what sounds like cluster bombs
Landing far too close by we head for the
doorway to shelter
the basement for Larry shouts come come
he says I'm used to it everyone piles
inside waiting for yet more incoming
bombs
Selena tells us it was quiet for just 10
minutes every day it's back and forth
like this flying over our heads
seconds later Valeria is punched by a
neighbor he's angry at Valeri for
bringing foreign journalists here many
blame us for prompting the bombings
this war has set pensioner against
pensioner and forced neighbors to turn
on each other
please tell the world what's happening
in donbass she says
and show please how it is
I'm trying not to cry she says I'm
trying to keep myself calm but you need
to tell them what the situation is
well this is going on all the time
constant barrage it's unbelievable that
there are so many people who are still
living and having to put up with this
they're right in the middle of it
at the aid Hub more injured have been
brought in and one woman has got a very
nasty head wound there's no gunshot
wound there's just a shrapnel the worst
injuries to her head but she just needs
to get evacuated for that
it turns out Sky News colleague Nick
Davenport is the most qualified medic
here probably in the whole of the city
there's a police trained first aider too
who asked not to be identified
there are two badly wounded here but
most certainly not the only ones in dire
need of medical health in the city
Emma is back with her Evac team but her
vehicle has broken down so she's
urgently trying to find replacements
we only have
somehow the aid Hub manager finds a way
out for them
this is going to be a difficult and
dangerous Journey for them but at least
they have hope there's very little of
that going around this city right now as
the Russian troops pose in Alex Crawford
Sky News in separate the Mets in eastern
Ukraine
okay
well now Professor Michael Clark is here
with me and we start with some questions
on that City from which Alex Crawford
was reporting welcome once again to you
Michael and uh let's kick straight off
in with Paul's question Paul asks is it
possible for Ukrainian forces to hold
back the Russian advance in cimoro
Donetsk what are we understand then
about the balance of force it's very
difficult the Russians have now
effectively surrounded severeign
and Southern pincers to the west of the
city are probably 10 or 12 miles apart
but I would expect them to actually
close those pincers close that
encirclement let's say in the next 24 48
Hours the Russians are putting
everything into this particular part of
the front they've they've paused
elsewhere or they're not making very
much progress elsewhere but they're
putting everything into a severeign so
they will surround the city pretty
pretty soon that's not the same as
taking it because we've got to decide on
what the Ukrainian force is inside
Sovereign well that's the next question
Following on from that James asks if you
were in charge of Ukrainian forces
if you were in charge of Ukrainian
forces in severe danetsk would you
withdraw yeah I'm very glad that I'm not
I have to say
um it's the it's the the hardest call
for any commander essentially it depends
on a really a simple calculation in a
way if you're going to allow yourself to
be surrounded and and ride out some sort
of Siege you you can only really do that
if you think there's a realistic chance
that at some point quite soon your
forces will be able to break through and
break The Siege so if if the commander
feels that Ukrainian forces will be
capable of mounting some sort of
counter-attack and fight their way back
through to them to keep severeign
Ukrainian hands then it might be worth
it if you don't think the siege could be
lifted then you're only with
withstanding a siege for some symbolic
or maybe humanitarian reason to protect
civilians or something like that but in
strict military terms
um if you if you don't think you're
going to be relieved then it's probably
best to withdraw and let the city go and
we've talked then you talked there about
the concentration of Russian forces in
this area well Adrian asked
strategically what is more important for
Ukraine to defend the donbass or Odessa
so where does Ukraine concentrate its
defenses does it have enough to split
them yeah if you had to choose you
choose to keep Odessa open the donbass
is
um it's very important area of Ukraine
but it's the area of Ukraine which has
suffered Civil War already and there's
an awful lot of Devastation there and in
a way the rest of Ukraine has adjusted
to the the problem of the donbass since
2014 but Odessa is the window on the sea
the window on the outside world and
while Odessa is open at the moment of
course it's blockaded but if Odessa is
open then Ukraine
um has a window on the sea otherwise
it's landlocked so strategically I would
say Odessa matters more than and that
whole Coastline Odessa mariopol matters
more uh sorry I said mikalayev Odessa
Michaela of matters more than the
donbassador and in terms of the
distribution of Ukrainian forces of
course we still can't forget Kiev and
there are reports of Belarusian troop
movements to the north there are but um
I mean what the belarusians have done is
they've got the Special Forces
exercising up and down the Border I
don't think they're going to cross the
border for all sorts of reasons that you
know we've spoken about
um but and the ukrainians have only got
a screening Force they've essentially
got their territorial Defense Force and
some reserves screening it so at the
moment the ukrainians are not actually
allowing the belarusians to draw too
much of their forces away and they can't
afford to but I think they must have a
backup plan to actually move forces
quickly and remember they've still got a
railway system with a good 22 23 000
kilometers of track so they can move
forces quite quickly if they have to in
Ukraine so at the moment I think they're
only screening this Belarusian uh
gesture and at the moment I think it is
only a gesture well that's uh follow up
with another question about Odessa and
of course the the fact that it's on the
sea and uh Mark asked this Mike Russia
try to take Odessa with an amphibious
Landing because of course it can try
trolls the sea outside of this very very
difficult an amphibious Landing alone an
amphibious element to a ground offensive
makes perfect sense but amphibious
Landings alone are extraordinarily
difficult and dangerous not many
countries can do it
um and they're always risky I mean the
two great examples in British military
history was one was Gallipoli in 1915 an
amphibious landing on the Bosphorus the
troops got onto the beach Turkish forces
got onto The High Ground above them and
they were they were stuck on the beach
for 10 months 10 months before they were
withdrawn the whole thing was miserable
it was a failure the other great one of
course was D-Day and and the interesting
thing about D-Day it was a huge
operation the biggest Invasion the
biggest amphibious invasion in history
Bar None
um extremely complex every Last Detail
was thought about and yet it still came
down to one brutal Fact one brutal
equation is that could the Allies on the
6th of June 1944 for could they get 150
000 men onto the beaches and into their
sort of fingertip hold on the peninsula
and if they were still there and mainly
alive 24 hours later then the invasion
has succeeded because there was so much
coming in behind them but it was a huge
risk and Eisenhower who was the he was
the the architect of course he was the
Supreme Commander he wrote ahead of the
invasion he wrote his failure note he
wrote the note of the of what he was
going to say if it failed saying you
know it was my decision nobody else was
responsible it was mine alone and he had
that it was a handwritten note and he
put it in his battle dress pocket and he
kept it with him for several days until
he re until he was sure that an invasion
had succeeded because we know what
happened we take it for granted it
couldn't have failed absolutely it could
have failed they are hugely risky things
to try amphibious operation and Russia
has nothing approaching those kinds of
devices nothing like that I mean they
can they can they can mount amphibious
Landings but you know if I were a
Russian Commander I would certainly not
want to try to to take Odessa given that
the opposition know you're coming if
you're taken by surprise that's
different but if the opposition are
expecting you the fact is that your
troops coming into whether it's the port
or the beach that you're trying to
assault I mean they're sitting ducks for
two miles out until they arrive and even
when they arrive they're they're very
vulnerable until they establish some
sort of toe hold and then the
reinforcements can arrive and that
usually takes many many hours okay well
let's talk now about the economic War we
all know about the economic sanctions
being visited upon Russia but now the
extreme sanctions that are being
returned by Russia through the form of
food exports so Kev asked this to help
get Seabourn exports flowing to and from
Odessa could NATO provide Ukraine with
anti-ship missiles to create a protected
sea Corridor presumably it already has
because there was the sinking of that
great battle cruising yes I mean the
Moscow that went down actually with
ukrainians uh Ukraine's own missiles the
Neptune which they seem to be the first
time they'd use them so they hit a
bullseye I think first time but they
they're being supplied with Harpoon uh
nature weapons which an american-based
weapon very very capable with a range of
about 80 miles you know 140 150
kilometers something like that and they
will make a difference to the ukrainians
as we're keeping Russian ships further
out for safety but that's a different
thing to
um you know creating a protected C
Corridor because a protected C Corridor
we're not you see what the the thought
is behind the question you know is it
possible to create some sort of a
humanitarian sea Corridor so that
tankers and um grain ships in particular
can get in and out of Odessa and get all
this food which is backed up in Ukraine
out to World Markets which are suffering
grievously for lack of Ukrainian grain
well well and asked more or less the
same question if the blacks see around
Odessa is in international waters why
can't it be patrolled by NATO as a
deterrent and this some talk today of
the UK leading a coalition of the
willing to try to protect those Series
yeah this was this was a conversation
between the Lithuanian foreign minister
and our own foreign minister Liz truss
it's not been taken up elsewhere and
it's all very very speculative
um because if there were a an
international force of any sort but
particularly one involving NATO ships
then they'd be challenging the Russians
um to they'd be daring the Russians to
stop them and it would be a pretty
dangerous thing to have to do there's
been some talk why doesn't why doesn't
Egypt do it Egypt's got green ships and
they've got some warships so why don't
they do it remember too that the
Bosphorus the route into the Black Sea
is closed at the moment because turkey
controls that and they won't allow any
warships through to the black seed
they'll let Warships come out but it's
their privilege on the international law
to stop more more warships going in so
the Turkish government would have to
agree to it somebody would have to be
prepared to take on daring the Russians
and it's hard to imagine it happening
without the Russians agreeing and the
Russians will only agree they have in
did if sanctions in some way are
lessened and so they they wouldn't agree
for humanitarian reasons they'll only
agree if they get something pretty big
out of it to actually lessen the
pressure on them so it's a it's a
devil's bargain to be honest
questions now uh several about how the
war might end or how a stalemate might
lead to an end to the fighting whatever
we've got this question here
um if Ukraine gave the donbass region to
Russia could the U.N police a buffer
zone well of course so Russia's part of
the United Nations but uh I see see what
the questioner means improves I mean
there was before the before the war
broke out from 2014 when the Russians
last invaded there was an osce
monitoring Mission there the osc is the
organization for security and
cooperation in Europe so it's like a
region it's like a mini UN in Europe uh
composed of 57 Nations 57 European
nations and the um uh the osce had a
quite a big monitoring mission in the
donbass to try to report on violations
of the ceasefire that were established
under the Minsk agreement and Minsk 2
and so on but of course because it
involved all the nations of the osce
including Russia some of the monitors
were Russians and some of the
monasteries were belarusians and some of
the monitors were German and Italian and
Ukrainian
and so um what the nearer we got to the
invasion in February the more the
Russian monitors were seeing something
completely different to what the German
monitors imagine that
well the thing is the monitoring Mission
got less and less credible but it did a
good job with some very brave people to
be honest from 2014 right through to
2021 so yes it is possible to have a
monitoring Mission but all of these
monitoring missions all they can do when
we say you know can they police a buffer
zone well you can observe in a buffer
zone but if you're going to police a
buffer zone you have to have troops who
are prepared to fight back or fire back
if they're fired on and that's a very
different issue altogether
okay uh well uh another question uh this
one from Ronnie asking if Russia takes
the Don bass I mean this effectively is
about yeah you know what will Russia
want what does Russia want what its war
ends are after altering the uh the
original battle plan of taking the
entirety of Ukraine if Russia takes the
donbass will they keep going or will the
war end well I think the short answer is
this phase of the war might end because
President Putin's in a real mess uh it's
getting worse and if he could walk away
with something now then he might go for
some sort of ceasefire he might make
some offer which would be hard for some
of the European countries to refuse
um but he wouldn't put an end to the
wall because as far as we understand and
the you know looking at everything Putin
has said in the last 10 years
particularly in the last
um eight or ten months this man still
wants to destroy Ukraine as an
independent state he doesn't believe
Ukraine has a right to exist it should
be a part of Russia it should be the
little Russia that it always used to be
um and so a donbass victory might be
enough of an incentive for him to end
this particular phase but nobody
absolutely nobody in the analysis
business believes that he would not then
try to engineer a future crisis and do
the same thing again when he's learned
some of the lessons of this particularly
disaster so it wouldn't end the conflict
it would end this phase of the conflict
perhaps and it's also about the pressure
or not put upon Ukraine we know the
ukrainians vastly don't want to seed any
territory and they want back what they
lost in 2014 as well but none other than
Henry Kissinger today at the Davao loss
Summit was suggesting some seeding of
territory to to bring this to an end as
quickly as possible yeah that's Henry
he's a he's a great 19th century
strategist which I'm not being rude
about him he's a wonderful character
with a very very sharp mind
um but he he thinks in bismarckian terms
that you have to do deals and deals are
if territory seems to matter to people
then it matters even though in the
modern world you think well in a
globalized world why should it but if it
seems to then it does and again he's
being pragmatic and saying that you know
Russia is a country that that we're
going to live with for the foreseeable
future Russia is part of Europe and Asia
if you can't wish it away just because
Putin is in control at the moment and so
we've got to think about bringing this
conflict to an end in order to get on to
better terms and and move forward I
understand that but I my view and I
would disagree with Kissinger here
gosh me disagree in the kitchen but I
would disagree with him and I have in
the past
um is that this actually this is so
important that the world has changed the
post-war world has changed because of
this Invasion and that the whole of the
Western World Western liberal democracy
is under Threat by this Invasion so our
duty is not to end the war our duty if
we can is to help Ukraine win it in
terms that strengthen Western democracy
and diminish the power of unprovoked
aggression in the modern world okay well
I'm going to follow through on that I've
got another question but uh sand Max
asks the broad question then more or
less if not that then what when will
this will end in Morton Point how then
if it's not about some slices of land in
exchange for a ceasefire if it is as
existential as you describe then we're
back to what do we do about Putin aren't
we yeah absolutely I think it's two glib
answers they're not wrong but they're
just glib but I mean one is you know
War's end when both sides or all sides
think that they can't gain any more
politically by fighting
they keep on fighting when they think
it's doing them some good politically
once you know if and if one side may
decide that it's not doing them anymore
good the other side if they do think
it's doing doing them some good is in a
very dominant position but Wars end when
fighting does not seem to be achieving
any of the political things that they
want and when the sides have got to that
point then they tend to get interested
in negotiations and they try then to get
the best out of the situation that
they've put themselves in and neither
side at the moment Ukraine or Russia is
in that situation presently they both
think it is worth continuing to fight
for the different reasons how might it
end
it ends in a way this is the existential
issue it ends for us when Putin goes
um you know we my view is we can't live
with Putin's Russia in a in a future
stable Europe I mean he has destabilized
Europe and will continue to destabilize
it so for me this goes on not
necessarily the fighting but the the the
struggle with Russia the conflict with
Russia the fact that we're not going to
play nice games with him anymore this
goes on for as long as he is there okay
we've got some more questions about
Putin and his future coming up in the
next half of this program but on the
issue then the fighting continues a lot
of our viewers have asked this question
and I've asked it in the past and
continue to ask and continue to wonder
why isn't Ukraine attacking Targets in
Russia or even bombing Moscow given that
they're being attacked in their
territory why don't they do a bit of Tit
for Tat two quick reasons one is bombing
Moscow wouldn't make any difference
militarily
um it would just be an outrageous thing
in the Russian eyes to do and secondly
more importantly in a way it would
destroy Ukraine's moral superiority and
the the point about Ukraine is that
everyone in the west pretty well in the
west not in the rest of the world is on
Ukraine's side because they are victims
of an unprovoked attack they are the
victims of clear aggression and as long
as they stick to trying to throw the
Russians out of their country nobody can
disagree with that as an objective if
they started to attack Russia even
though in in military war terms there
might be some rationale not Moscow but
say belgarod just over the border which
is a supply of if they're starting to
bomb Belgrade in any significant way
they would they would although
militarily that would make some sort of
sense it would destroy the moral
superiority which at present Ukraine is
able to trade on well our next question
is from someone who clearly has some
deep military knowledge it's from
someone called Riley who asks this uh
there are reports of Russia equipping
btgs with the t-62 tank considering the
age of these tanks will have a big
impact on the battles in donbass so tell
us about t60 twos and btgs yeah or the
t62 goes back to about 1961. it's an old
very old tank there's a lot of them are
in the world I mean the Russians sold
them to all sorts of countries around
the world so you can see them in lots of
places in the world
um they had the Russians have got about
5 000 tanks in storage of which about I
think two two and a half thousand are
probably meant to be t-62s and they the
Russians were supposed to have got rid
of all their tank stocks a while ago
then it turned out that they hadn't or
the t-62 stocks turned out they hadn't
they'd sent a lot of them to Syria which
you where you can still see them in
Assad's forces
um if the t-62s are turning up in the
the btgs which are the Battalion
tactical groups which is the fighting
unit it's like how many men uh it's
about 700 it's a bit like a battle group
for in in Western terms so it's like a
battalion some of them wrote a thousand
some of them down to 500 depends what
they what their job is really but um if
some of them are turning up in these
armored btgs then I wouldn't be he I
wouldn't give much for the cruise of
them because they're not very
um they're not very good in taking fire
they're quite vulnerable and they are
old but the Russians May well be they're
certainly cutting into their stocks and
they are having to bring more tanks out
what we've what we've seen is most of
the tanks are the you know the
ubiquitous t-72s which and that's what
ukrainians have there's a few t80s in
the battle and I've and I've seen a
couple of t90s which are very modern
tanks we haven't seen any of their their
Space Age tank is called the armata the
T14 which looks like a piece of Space
Age kit we haven't seen any of those yet
and I don't think we will so effectively
this is a battle that will be won and
lost with the t-72 if the Russians are
bringing the t-62s into the into the
equation then I think the Ukrainian
anti-tank missiles will do even better
well that's about the hardware what
about the Personnel last question for
this section on that again oft asked and
often wondered about how significantly
would the situation change you Putin
ordered full all mobilization of his
forces and that would turn it into
Russia accepting its a war yeah
absolutely and it would make a huge
difference in terms of personnel because
the Russian army the peacetime Army that
they're drawing from at the moment is
only 280 000 but they've got more than a
million people that they can mobilize if
they have to in theory and so if and
they are short of people on the ground
it's not undoubtedly true that Russian
forces are strict very thinly even for
what they're trying to do now so it
would make a big difference in terms of
bringing new people in but remember if
you declared nobilization tomorrow those
forces that are reconscripted or
conscripted are not going to turn up for
at least five or six months they do two
months basic training four to five
months specialized training so you're
talking about Christmas time in November
December before any new troops could
appear on the battlefield and the other
thing is that they they're not going to
get more equipment there they're
bringing out their old stocks of
equipment like with the tank uh area
tank supplies but they're finding it
very difficult to produce new equipment
because sanctions have actually stopped
the import of components many of which
come from the West so unless Mr Putin
gets a lot of Hardware from China which
at the moment is not he can increase his
numbers of troops eventually but even
then we'll we'll struggle to actually
increase the amount of equipment okay
we'll pause it there Michael thanks very
much indeed for what we've covered so
far you are watching a question and
answer program about the war in the
Ukraine up next after the break
questions about Germany's contributions
to the war effort and Putin's nuclear
threats
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Sky News tonight's question and answer
program about the warn Ukraine with
Professor Michael Clarke in this section
we're going to be answering some of your
questions about the international
response to Russia's invasion of Ukraine
and the assistance being offered by NATO
countries and earlier today Sky News
spoke to the mayor of Kiev Vladimir
Klitschko and his brother they're in
Davos in Switzerland for the annual
World economic Forum the brothers called
for a unified International response and
warned that the conflict could
destabilize all of Europe
I have a message for every politician
right now in Ukraine in here in the Ross
to everyone in Europe around the world
if somebody
think the war is somewhere far away from
me
the the war doesn't touch me personally
is the biggest mistake this war and the
largest country in Europe can
destabilize situation in whole region
was the consequences of this war and the
consequences eventually are very scary
Ukraine is one of the biggest
delivers of green to Africa and Asia and
with the blocking of the Black Sea
obviously we will have hunger in those
regions can I show you something this is
we have a reporter and a team right now
in the donbass
can I just show you this is the filming
they have done for the last few days
the war has horrible face
we saw the consequences in
satellite cities as bushing a tunnel
just to name a few
um
the war has horrible face we've seen all
those dead bodies of young women men
older men
um
being just killed
you could tell they were tortured before
execute it with the headshots
with the tight hands behind the back
you could see you could smell
you could tell The Silence of the death
and destruction of all the
infrastructure and buildings
so War has many horrible faces
and this war was started
by Russia
if we don't stop it if we don't sanction
it if we don't isolate it with one front
on gas oil
call
athletic team here in Switzerland the
ioc in Los Angeles IEC headquarter
and it's not just the decision must be
made too to isolate
from the next upcoming Olympics the
Russian team
nothing is the athletes or nationalities
but to show to Russia this war and the
world is not okay with that this war
crime must be stopped
whether we have the Klitschko brothers
they're in Davos at the world economic
Forum with as you could hear there are a
warning for the world and to call for
more International support so let's get
on with your questions because we
addressed that through Bradley's
question who asks and uh he asks a
specific question Michael why do you
think Germany is being very slow and
providing heavy equipment to Ukraine of
course the mighty economic power that is
Germany its support is crucial both in
terms of those gas supplies but also in
terms of of the Weaponry so so why is it
slow in providing that Heavy Artillery
yes I mean Chancellor Schultz whose SPD
is the left of center party made some
very dramatic statements early on in
this crisis saying that Germany would
increase this defense expenditure would
drop its opposition to supplying weapons
would allow other countries who had
German components in their weapons to
supply which includes the Dutch and the
Danes for instance that was quite
important but themselves the Germany
itself has been really slow in supplying
weapons because they to be honest
they're a study in ambiguity this is
this is agonizing for them because the
SPD is identified with being not
pro-russia but but believing that you
could deal with Russia that you could
civilize Russia into European society
that you could do trade and you could
bring Russia in to the family of Nations
but he's now presiding over what's
called a traffic-like coalition so um
his um foreign minister uh is a green uh
Angelina
um
she's one of the greens and the greens
are very tough on Russia for moral
reasons
um and the Finance Minister is FTP the
Liberals and they're quite tough on
Russia for business reasons or different
business reasons and so he's presiding
over a coalition of three parties that
don't normally sit together in
government so it is difficult however I
have to say I think that the German
public is probably ahead of the
government on this because the German
public is so outraged by what they see
in Ukraine I think that they are urging
their government to be a bit more
proactive but Schultz he said all the
right things but he's slow in carrying
them through but I also cautious man are
they also in part held back by their
history I mean the last time forces or
German equipment in Ukraine we know what
happened I I mean I sat through I don't
know how many meetings years and years
ago when everyone would complain in NATO
or the Germans won't do this and the
Germans won't do that and I used to say
look don't complain this is the Germany
we wished for for 150 years this is a
civilian Germany who only wants to do
things in a civilian way who does not
want to resort to military power and
that is the case I mean this Germany at
the heart of NATO is very reluctant to
go down the military path and that's
because of the effect not just the
second war but the first world war the
20th century was a disaster for Germany
Germany should have been Far and Away
the most important European power if you
look at the situation of Germany in 1890
they should have dominated Europe but
dominated in all the right ways the 20th
century instead of instead of which they
wrecked themselves into disastrous Wars
Let's uh follow through on more
questions about equipment for Ukraine
and this is revisiting one that has been
asked since the beginning of the
invasion Mark asks How likely is it that
the West will give Ukraine fighter jets
as I say we've been talking about that
since February yeah I mean the short
answer is increasingly so
um the they want mig-29s but we've said
before that you know they're not the
bill and end all they may be an air
superiority Fighter
um but they won't help in terms of
holding back Russian Ground Forces they
really need more su-30 su-25s which are
the sort of air ground bombing aircraft
and they could certainly do with some of
those and they could get them uh from
the West it's not not much point trying
to give Ukraine you know sort of f-16s
the you know falcon or the new version
the Viper or whatever it is uh because
it would take too long to train the
pilots not the pilots couldn't do it of
course they could but um it would just
take too long when they're fighting a
war for survival so I think the short
answer is the the the barriers to giving
Ukraine fight fighter jets are going
smaller and smaller but the thing that
makes the most difference to Ukraine's
air power is not so much the aircraft as
the ground-based anti-aircraft systems
which are remarkably effective against
Russian aircraft okay lots more
questions to get through this one from
down about the UK uh Dan says the UK has
been supporting Ukraine and has faced
very little retaliation why is this is
the fight taking place in the gray Zone
yeah it is no he's absolutely right I
mean there is a sort of cyber battle
going on as we speak every day and it's
going on we assume in both directions
not it's not just them attacking us we
assume that we're trying to uh get in
their way and make them trip over their
own feet in relation to things in
Ukraine and we're certainly giving
Ukraine the best help we can which is
pretty effective so far in cyber
um so I think that it is going on in the
gray Zone but again it comes back to
there's a clear Red Line in this whole
crisis that we've talked about before
which both sides recognize that that
NATO and Russian forces will not fight
each other directly and so far that line
is strong and it is held and for the
foreseeable future I would expect it to
continue to hold and so the Russians
also know they can only push us so far
even though they talk as if we are the
great Satan and we control everything
that happens and so the pairs they pass
the complement of thinking that we're
behind everything David asked this
interesting one this uh why are we
revealing what is being supplied to
Ukraine is that not something to be kept
secret from the Russian so well is
everything being revealed no
um I mean the things that are clear I
mean if you've gone to supply tanks and
artillery pieces and so on that
journalists will report it you can see
it there there's no reason to try to
keep that secret because we want to
celebrate the fact that we live in a
world with a free press
um but I think that there's another
issue here which is that supplying
weapons is also a symbol we're trying to
convince the rest of the world and our
allies and our friends things that we
mean it that we're we're doing this
explicitly and we want the Russians to
know we're doing it explicitly and we'll
keep on doing it which is why um the
American offer of 40 billion in Aid of
which the vast majority will go to
military aid is a really important
symbol and the Americans are saying look
we're sent 90 M triple seven howitzers
which are really good 155 millimeter
houses we've sent them most of them are
there and they're announcing this
because they want the Russians to know
do you want the ukrainians to know they
want the Germans to know and the
Italians and the Spanish and everybody
else to know that we're in that we the
backers of Ukraine are in this for the
long term so yeah we're keeping some of
it quiet on the intelligence and cyber
side but when it comes to heavy metal
you can't disguise it anyway so
celebrate it okay I've plenty more
questions to come but a break more
immediately you're watching a question
and answer program about the war in
Ukraine up next Putin may have nuclear
weapons in many of them but does he have
the power to launch them stay with us
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I'm in zamam Rasheed and I'm Skies north
of England correspondent telling stories
from this culturally Rich region I call
home
it's going to become very similar to
other places and lose its unique
qualities it's steeped in history
if the Taliban found your family what
would happen I think they're just going
to straight away execute them
there are issues of racism in all levels
of cricket I was in the balcony a couple
of times I was nearly gone
football is a joy to watch and when
people are disappointed you can feel the
hate
[Music]
I just felt physically safe so I was
like that that's really in my system
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
even before the pandemic GPS were
pleading for help government expects
more face-to-face contact with patients
in return
men they want to force you doing
something which you don't want to do
just because you're homeless and you're
looking for a warm place to sleep
we give a voice to communities often
unheard and unserved from a region with
a distinct history and Global impact
[Music]
right then we've got Michael Clark here
answering your questions your very good
questions about Ukraine and Mark asks
this for our last section he says let's
talk of President Putin being removed
from Power who might take over and would
they be more friendly to the west or
perhaps would they at least not have the
ego of Vladimir Putin I mean the short
answer is we've no idea who might take
over and whoever it is that probably
wouldn't be more friendly to the West
certainly in the immediate uh term but
however anyone who is not Putin will
think about where they are and one would
hope be a bit more pragmatic but I mean
we all play these parlor games now is
that you know who is there around Putin
because he's surrounded Now by so few
people that he seems to believe and who
are genuinely powerful most powerful
person to emerge in the last few months
is Patricia from Nicolette Patricia who
is his National Security Council Chief
in effect he's an old friend he's he's
more Putin than Putin on Ukrainian
issues he's very very nationalist Ultra
Nationalist and effectively imperialist
and then there's bortnikov who is the
FSB head head of the you know the
security service who's an old friend of
Putin they go back a long way and then
the Sega lavrov foreign minister and
lavrov has I mean he used to be a
different person a few years ago you
know but he's really gone to the dark
side as Putin has and lavrov too has got
enormous power we believe so you'd look
at those three uh Patricia thoughtnikov
lavrov as possible successors who might
step up in a crisis if if Putin died or
if he was removed or maybe one of them
would remove him we're guessing totally
but then you think about medridev who
had been president and prime minister or
matushin who's the current prime
minister not really they don't seem to
have that much of a power base or shogu
um the defense minister he seems very
ill but he's powerful Putin trust him
the man who doesn't seem to figure now
is grazimov Who is the the head of the
Armed Forces you know he seems to have
been wounded a couple of weeks ago in
Islam he wasn't at the MayDay rally he
has been seen with Putin since I think
for propaganda purposes but he hasn't
been seen much so I we think that
grazimov is either more ill than or more
wounded than we thought or he is out of
favor but you know when you look around
you you fingers are one hand are the
people that we think have got power
um but not necessarily going to take a
difference absolutely it's hard to see
somebody from an outsider stepping in
without us seeing them step up before
they step in so it's a very good
question it's one we ask ourselves on a
daily basis at the moment asking yeah
here's a good one from Paul who focusing
back on Ukraine again how are the
civilian pro-russian ukrainians viewing
the Russian troops of course many of
them being living under effectively
Russian rule for seven or eight years
now yeah there's not that many of these
people now I mean we know that of the 14
million displaced people in Ukraine 14
million out of 44 or a million of are
now out of their homes and all those 14
million about a million are in Russia
and about half a million of that million
are seem to be there involuntarily
they've just been carted away and they
are in effect political prisoners but
about half a million seem to have left
voluntarily who we assume are people who
would prefer to live in Russia than live
in the Ukraine at War so the number of
pro-rushing ukrainians is probably very
small at the moment that's what we're
guessing because those who are
pro-russian have had ease it's been easy
for them to just leave
um there's lots of ways they could have
got out the Ukraine is not a closed
Society so they could have just gone
over the board in many places and just
gone to Russia
um I think a bigger issue not unrelated
to this is people saying look I don't
care whether I live under Russian or
Ukrainian rule I just want to live and
you know a number of of um
correspondents I think have been showing
up this that when you get nearer to
celebrity Done Yet a lot of these people
say I just wanted to stop and if it
means the Russians winning well so be it
I don't care because I just want to be
alive at the end of this and that's a
very understandable human reaction not
everyone is fiercely Ukrainian I mean
everyone in Ukraine is a Ukrainian
Patriot but some people are more Fierce
than others about it and some people who
are in the conflict Zone just want to
still be there in a year's time now here
we get to a question that uh seems to
always come up and it concerns the
entire world of course so Lawrence asks
this one and I suppose it's as we were
just discussing if it's a cornered Putin
a Putin is losing the war and Ill Putin
a Putin who fears he's going to be
removed in a coup if he orders a nuclear
strike what is defense staff have to
obey yes uh in theory if the if the
chief of the state if the head of state
and the Chief of the Armed Forces uh
give an order then in theory everyone
has to obey it whether they would or not
would depend on the circumstances and I
mean you know as we said there are the
Russians have got about 1 900 tactical
nuclear weapons all with a quite a
complex command system it goes from the
Kremlin right down to the battlefield
lots of people in the way who might
question the or order or want
clarification or slow it down or want to
make sure that they had something
written before they took action if we're
talking about strategic nuclear weapons
nuclear weapons that are fired from
submarines that's direct from Mr Putin
to the submarine Captain so there's not
very many people in the way it's but
it's the case I have to say in every
country I mean if um if the British
prime minister issued the order then yes
the rest of the system would be required
to obey the order simple as that
well um let's uh end on on this note
unfortunately another viewer asks so
what system does the UK have to defend
itself against a Russian nuclear attack
and given from what you just said There
Michael I'm not at all not a lot no no
it's not at all it's not at all okay
look to defend itself the the issue is
that if you can't defend yourself
against an attack and most missile
attacks whether nuclear conventional
very hard to defend yourself against the
ballistic missile attack ballistic
missiles which go into space and then
come down very very fast
um all you can do is deter so you can't
defend against them with any certainty
there's a bit of there's a bit of
missile defense around in the world the
Americans have got a system but it would
only work against one or two missiles
maybe six or seven at most Britain
doesn't have these things and so our
only response is not defense but
deterrence so we say yes we know we are
vulnerable but we have our continuous at
Sea deterrence Cas D CSD which means
that one we have four nuclear submarines
at any given moment one of them is out
somewhere under the North Atlantic and
within 55 minutes of the Prime Minister
giving the order can fire its missiles
against whoever struck us so it's
nervous times at the moment are these
hotlines you know we all remember from
the Cold War when they when the generals
and indeed the commanders in Chief the
leaders were able to talk directly to
each other and if somebody misread
someone else's intentions they were able
to calm it all down are they still in
operation they are and they're much
better I mean when we used to talk about
the hotlines they weren't hotlines at
all in Hollywood it's a telephone that
they pick up and talk to they wasn't
like that it was a teleprinter that took
hours to go backwards and forwards it
was it was astonishingly cruel Doctor
Strange Love was right absolutely the
more I see doctor Strangelove the more
puff from the very end where Slim
Pickens goes down on the nuclear that's
the only bit that's surreal the rest of
it believe me there is something in our
nuclear history where I can tick off yes
that's happened that's happened that's
happened and that's happened It's a
Wonderful film Kubrick's Great
Masterpiece Dr Strangler it gets less
surreal the more you the more you watch
it however deterrence is is about this
this ability to respond and and yet we
have that ability
um whether it's a safe thing to do who
knows but I have to say let's not forget
that Millie the American uh chairman of
the Joint Chiefs was in touch with
grazimov uh sorry with the uh uh you
know gorasimov this week and Lloyd
Austin the defense Chief was in touch
with shogu this week so the Americans
and the Russians are at the top level
they're phoning each other and talking
to each other in order to keep the
temperature as low as they can as
military professionals Michael
informative as ever if not more so thank
you very much indeed Michael Clark there
and you've been watching a question and
answer program on Sky News tonight about
the war in Ukraine and uh coming up on
Sky News at eight o'clock
foreign
[Music]